also meine These ist natürlich dass wir
Frieden und Freiheit verteidigen müssen
zurzeit und das natürlich einige
Beschwerden ist geben wird noch einige
soziale Härten geben wird wir haben
ausführlich darüber gesprochen aber das
sind Dinge die kurzfristig ins weh tun
aber mittleren langfristig werden uns
Frieden Freiheit Wohlstand bringen und
auch und auch
allgemeine allgemeines Glückseligkeit
wenn ich mal so sagen darf das heißt
gibt auch Amerika hat dort als ein
Beitrag geleistet und das ist mein
zentrale These Amerika unterstützt hier
ist eine der größten der Schütze wenn
ich sehr großer Schütze der Ukraine
zurzeit und vertritt dort eben und
Frieden und Freiheit und eben auch
Gesetzmäßigkeiten und das eben niemand
durch Europa gehen kann kann die Grenzen
neu ziehen und sagen ich bin jetzt hier
und annektiere Gebiete
völkerrechtswidrig sondern dass wir eben
dafür einstehen und dass wir eben
verteidigen wie Deutschland verteidigt
worden ist von den eben nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg Herr Freund ich habe hier
direkt eine Frage sie haben gerade
gesagt es wird uns wehtun sprechen Sie
davon Deutschland oder von Amerika und
welche Opfer hat bislang Amerika
gebracht im ukrainekrieg also einige
Opfer gebracht auch die Gaspreise und
die Ölpreise sind genauso gestiegen in
USA wie Frankreich profitiert nein nein
die Ölindustrie nein nein
Amerika kann ich Ihnen sagen die
Ölindustrie machten Amerika ungefähr 6%
des Sozialproduktes aus also das ist
unbedeutend was viel mehr wehtut ist wir
Amerika rutscht jetzt auch in die
Rezession rein Amerika zahlt genauso die
gleichen hohen Energiekosten und Amerika
hat sogar ein Viertel nicht doch nein
Amerika profitiert das Energie und Gas
betrifft das ist nicht dass sie dieselbe
Kosten haben wie Deutschland
doch immer nein
also ganz langsam Amerika rutschen
Rezession rein die in Amerika
unglaublich gestiegen haben es ebenfalls
verdreifacht die Ölpreise handelt auch
gestiegen USA und Amerika ist übrigens
energieintensiver als Deutschland auch
das stimmt kann ich Ihnen sagen wir
sehen in Deutschland weniger prozentual
betrachtet vom Sozialprodukt
energieintensiv als die USA also Amerika
wird genauso getroffen von den
Wirtschaftssanktionen wie Deutschland
eben hochschießt und die Fett hat sogar
früher entsprechend über den Ukraine
kriegt die Wirtschaft Sanktionen treffen
Amerika genauso wie Deutschland die
wirtschaftsaktionen müssen aufpassen
höhere Energiepreise trifft die
amerikanische Volkswirtschaft
tendenziell stärker als die deutsche
Volkswirtschaft aber wer das dann nicht
so wenn Sie das so sagen dass wir
vielleicht auch gerade daraus in Impuls
nehmen diese Politik die wir führen zu
überdenken weil sie nämlich uns schadet
wie sie auch sagen Amerika ist falls es
nicht aber wenn Sie das so sagen nehme
ich das erstmal so es schadet auf jeden
Fall der Ukraine und schadet auch den
Menschen die in Russland haben reden
nicht von der Politik sondern von den
Menschen mit kurzfristig ganz genau
kurzfristig ich meine wir haben schon
ein Jahr Krieg ein Jahr ist doch gar
nichts vergleichen Sie mal da drin
schaut mal
entschuldigen
schauen Sie sich doch mal an Amerika hat
sich ein ist ein Kriegseintritt im
Zweiten Weltkrieg gehabt im Dezember
einen 40 und hat dann dreieinhalb Jahre
lang gekämpften hohen blutsoll geleistet
aber möchten Sie das war ein Jahr
möchten Sie nein wiederholen ja genau
aber was meinen die Alternative geht
auch das Szenario mit wir machen es mit
na das wir haben auf Putin keinen
Einfluss aber wir haben
durchmachen
nächste Woche stehen
also ich weiß mopolation
Amerika es ist doch so aber davon mal
abgesehen wissen Sie dieses Land hier in
dem wir glücklichen zufrieden leben hat
sich lange in Sicherheit gewinnt bei der
Amerikaner der schützende Hand über
Deutschland gehalten haben auf die Weise
konnten Milliarden gespart und die
Sozialprojekte geleitet werden und jetzt
sind wir gebeten einen gewissen Anteil
dieser letzten zu übernehmen und das ist
schon zu viel aber er Bruder und ich
habe kann doch nicht mehr so geführt
werden wie damals also da hat er halt
Stadion angesprochen
man kann die Krieger nicht vergleichen
wir können ja nicht 1941 bis heute
vergleichen man kann die Bedrohung durch
einen Diktator durch einen Tyrann durch
einen Massenmörder durch ein sehnenloses
menschliches Wesen man kann die
vergleichen
sie eingesetzt ja dann setze ich nicht
mehr genau also wäre es doch trotzdem
immer wieder müssen wir noch allen
Möglichkeiten also sie hätten eher die
Nazifizierung Europas in Kauf genommen
wenn Hitler gehabt hätte und kein
Risiken gemacht hätte ich hätte nicht
weggesehen wie viele Millionen Deutsche
ich werde auf die Straße gegangen ja ja
leider nicht im Gegensatz zu mir hätten
sie wahrscheinlich Verlauf der
Geschichte verändert nicht aber ich habe
zumindest
einmal bei Ukraine und Russland ja und
da ist schon meine Frage Bruder wie kann
es denn jetzt überhaupt ausgehen das
weiß ich nicht das weiß niemand es ist
sozusagen
das ist leider so der Zweite Weltkrieg
ist so ausgegangen wer ausgegangen ist
aufgrund jeder Zufälle zum Beispiel dass
ich Churchill durchgesetzt hat gegen die
Pro deutschen pro nazikräfte in England
in England ich hatte auch nicht so
kommen müssen natürlich ist ein Risiko
es ist ein Risiko für alle nur zu sagen
wir werden uns gar nicht weil unsere
gegenwärt in Aggressor nur noch stärker
im avozieren provoziert demütig da
stehen sie das geredet dass die NATO
sich auf die auf Russland zu bewegt hat
ich meine russland hat einen ganzen
Speckgürtel um sich gehabt von Trabanten
und sagen die Debatte zulassen die Stahl
auch angestoßen hat ja das weiß ich ja
Bruder aber die Debatte welcher Krieg
ist wichtiger als der andere das muss
man schon die Frage des Menschenrechts
universell das heißt es gibt ja nicht
nur Putin den Diktator in der Welt nein
es gibt noch diesen Mann dein Nordkorea
das ist Dickerchen ja aber wissen Sie
irgendwo muss man anfangen und am besten
man fängt von der Haustür an deswegen
finde ich Putin für gefährliche und
bedrohlicher als diesen diesen Bewegung
macht im im Sicherheitsrat absehen davon
bitte
in Sicherheitsrat und mit Nordkorea
nicht ganz zu vergleichen und gucken sie
an was für Massaker die angestellt haben
wie wir Putin Assad geholfen hat das
Land kaputt zu machen wie viele
Millionen Flüchtlinge da sind wie viele
Tote es da gegeben hat das hat uns auch
lange nicht interessant
aber wir haben dieses Feindbild Amerika
und wenn sie jetzt sagen Amerika
profitiert davon ich kenne das alles ich
bin mit der These aufgewachsen dass die
Amerikaner nur deswegen in Amerika
weniger und ein Wirtschaft sein
ohne zu kommentieren was der Bruder oder
ich sagen das wäre ganz freundlicher
Freund vielen Dank okay danke schön ja
ich möchte aber hier einmal das noch zu
ihnen sagen es ist ja schon so dass
gerade Deutschland mehr leidet also man
muss ja sagen wenn wir sagen Opfer
bringen Deutschland leidet mehr als
andere Länder und Herren
Wirtschaftssanktionen sie meinen als
andere europäische Länder wir leiden
mehr als beispielsweise Amerika unter
den Sanktionen und man fordert von uns
immer mehr wie viel kann Deutschland
denn machen bis Deutschland selbst
bankrott geht ich habe die fürs Mitleid
mit den tiefen Leiden der deutschen die
vielleicht schon dreimal noch zweimal im
Jahr einen Urlaub fahren können das ist
weitaus mehr als das ja Bruder bitte ich
ich verbiete mir diese Respektlosigkeit
gegenüber den Menschen in unserem Land
leiden und da sind eigentlich zu Flo ich
verbiete mir sowas
können sie ja trotzdem aber ich will
meine Stimme da ergeben und sagen dafür
stehe ich nicht ein dass sie sowas somit
vergleichen sie werden auch im Dritten
Reich auf die Straße gegangen ich wäre
auf jeden Fall ich gehe ich auch jetzt
auf die Straße und erhebe meine Stimme
für heute sein Land mit dem Dritten
Reich bitte nee ich vergleiche
Ungerechtigkeit mit Ungerechtigkeiten
und die sind damit schlecht gewesen und
falsch und sind heute schlecht und
falsch und wenn Menschen nicht einziehen
ihre nicht erheben dann passiert schlimm
mit und der ja eben unsere Stimme ich
weiß nicht wie weit sie meine Arbeit
kennen ich liebe meine Stimme und er hat
stellt dafür ein und ich habe nur mal zu
100000er von E-Mails bekommen von
Menschen und wenn die ihre Worte
erzählen dann sein finden die nicht
richtig oder erhebe ich meine Stimme und
sagen Sie einfach so nicht es tut mir
furchtbar leid dass sie auf ihre
Klienten keine Rücksicht nehmen ein paar
Millionen nochmal
bitte die Menschen nicht die sich
einsetzen nee habe ich sie kommen immer
von heute übrigens